[Music]
[Applause]
tonight is a great way to open the
celebration of the the week celebration
by celebrating the creative arts that
creative spirit that animates the arts
at MIT is the same kind of creative
blood that flows through so much of what
we do and I don't know who told you that
I like tap dancing but somehow people
have found out all kinds of things that
I like and then produce them
[Music]
it's wonderful to see so many of you
here tonight in support of our new
president I would like in particular to
thank all the students who are here
facing end-of-term finals and projects I
appreciate that you are here this
evening to celebrate with us and I wish
you the best of luck and finishing your
academic year the theme of our
inauguration indicates an uncommon place
it's the uniqueness of our culture our
style our values and our traditions that
really permeate all aspects of this
diverse Institute I heard about machine
UN's exhibition read about it at the
Olympics in Greece and I thought
wouldn't it be wonderful would it be
wonderful if we could see it here at MIT
and indeed tonight we are going to be
able to see this marvelous exhibit and I
think it is my my wonderful duty to call
for the exhibit and so with no further
ado I will simply say let the white
noise white light begin
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm actually hoping here that people can
discover it at 3 a.m. on their way back
home or back to the dorm and they can
just experience it kind of more
individually more independently
[Music]
two teams of high school aged kids will
be solving challenges such as build a
machine that can automatically fill up
your water balloons so you have to take
time out of your busy water balloon
fight my name is Amy Fitzgerald and I'm
an instructor at the Edgerton Center I'm
the outreach coordinator for our
outreach program we see more than 2,000
school children a year from public
private homeschooling groups we see Boy
Scout troops all sorts of groups coming
so I went after school programs where
kids come and actually yet from the very
age of 10 to to 16 used all sorts of
machine tools and actually build things
that they want for the purposes of like
learning engineering and science
this is the dreaded bridge do don't fall
into the I'm amazed at the range of
programs in K through 12 and the
commitment of the people who are running
these programs so really fabulous
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the 16th president
of the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology dr. Susan Hockfield
accompanied by the chairman of the
corporation dr. Dana me
[Music]
it is now official may I present to you
the 16th president of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology Susan Hockfield
[Applause]
[Music]
for in the purest sense this magnificent
gathering is the culmination of the
official welcome of president Hockfield
to MIT but the truth is that we've been
welcoming her since she first walked
into a roaring ovation in 10 to15 nearly
eight months ago at that moment there
was a collective and almost ethereal
embracing of her and her wonderful
family dr. thomas byrne and their
daughter elizabeth and at the same time
there was a feeling that in her being in
her heart she was already one of us and
so said quite simply president Susan
Hockfield as graduate students we are
very happy that you are here thank you
thank you all there are about a thousand
people here and I would guess I have
thanks that I could extend to each of
you it would take us well into tomorrow
afternoon and I know about you but you
know I've had a busy day but I want to
thank you all for being part of this
truly uncommon celebration of the things
we hold deeply in common it's been an
extraordinary night and an extraordinary
week it is a been a wonderful wonderful
showcase of some only a small set of the
marvelous things that MIT has to offer
one another in the world it is an
enormous privilege to be part of this
community thank you all for joining the
celebration thank you for being here
tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
Mike welcome to your reunion
[Applause]
president vest thank you very much for a
kind introduction I like to check that
phone can you hear me you can't we can
hear you very well
when we were setting this up with NASA
they were wondering if we'd be able to
get a good audio video and I can see you
guys great I'm glad you guys can hear me
and I said if anybody could do great
audio video its MIT MIT
15 years ago and everybody who is an
alumnus in front of me said you know if
those guys fast and boy it really does
and I'm sure I'll probably feel that way
after 20 and 25 years but the nice thing
about having time is given me a little
bit of perspective and and the view we
have on the planet from up here gives me
some more perspective and what MIT does
is very important the mission of MIT the
way that my Pete goes about teaching its
students and the way that MIT is not
afraid to be world class these are very
important things to the entire planet
[Music]
to 70 started long long ago in a place
actually not far away the basement of
this building we gave the students a
creativity kit and I was a graduate
student at the time worked closely with
the students and learned that for their
first design project it was really hard
for them to decide what to do so the
next year we decided that we'd give them
a kit of materials but give them a very
specific thing to try to accomplish and
they got into it immediately and that
sort of got the ball rolling and 270
began with a very simple contest that
involved making the machine go down a
hill in three minutes the 270 contest
evolved to where it is today when we
first started it was a simple machine
doing a single thing while people
watched and it was quite slow after a
while we had machines side-by-side doing
things so that you could see some
competition and then we got interested
in what happens if the machines actually
collide in the middle and compete for
territory from that we evolved
robotically controlled things and that
has become a much more interactive
interesting thing to watch but the most
important thing that happened was the
students took on the challenge they
competed like crazy but helped each
other each other in the process
that I think is one of the most
important things about 272 mm first
whole idea of it you can work together
but still compete and help each other a
shared environment a shared learning
experience a great model for what the
profession of Engineering ought to be
about I first came in contact and
actually heard about it when I was here
as an undergraduate and Woodie flowers
was my UROP advisor for actually I was
blueprinting an engine for my pickup
truck and I was kind of looking forward
to taking 270 but I had blown my engine
on my truck so he actually would read
let me at that point rebuild the engine
on my truck and so I was peripherally
involved I was always looking in on the
class she had looks like a lot of fun
but never really got around to doing it
always kind of wishing I had but
vicariously living it by helping my
friends and stuff
and then I graduated went off to work
came back as a professor and then I
taught one section in it because the
course has the main instructor in charge
of the whole class
were you really the manager or the
captain of the ship so if I recall there
was a committee for a while Nate and
they were debating to whom to give the
class to I said well we could the only
person who really should teach is Alex
because he has good taste in fashion and
we need someone good taste in fashion so
they asked me if I would do it even
though I have tenure and I said okay but
let's go ahead and involve the
undergraduates more and actually running
it and that'll be like a whole army of
people helping those worthy it was kind
of a birth of the undergraduate
assistant arm of it and we've been
having fun ever since
[Music]
the contest is just a lot of fun it's
one of the best classes I will ever take
I'm sure of it 270 rock - 70 s changed a
lot now it's remote control interactive
lots of things happening that happened
gradually the real thing it that has
change is that we've gone to radio
control from the old days of a tether so
now the machines have a lot more freedom
and it also means in designing the
contest we can put more things into it
so it's more like a pinball machine
at first the students were required to
do pencil drawings and devices before
they would go build them and most of
them wouldn't they just go building then
we learned drafting computer aided
drafting and they use those tools to
help a little bit now we're at the point
where you do solid models and tools are
become much more useful so students will
do that because it's actually fast and
works and we're getting the point now
where the own screen dynamic simulations
are good enough that you can actually
use them to get an insight about what's
going to happen so the kid is evolved
with the class with technology in
general we just give them primarily raw
materials
you know sheets of aluminum bars of
metal you know it just gears bearings
motors that's it we just give them the
most basic of LEGO bricks and then they
design cut fold well put together real
machinery from it I always try to change
you know the character of the
transportation problem if there is one
involved one year we had putting a
square peg in a round hole which was a
lot of fun and you know MIT students can
do that that's probably good experience
so the contests have not really changed
at all in the sense that they are to
provide a challenge to the students that
when you look at the contest
there is no single right answer no one
can look at this and say aha
that's how you win so if you get to the
end and there's four or five completely
different designs that are competitive
it's a good sign and it's fun because
all the students are all they're really
excited and it's not just no no no the
problem said let's see it's like wow I'm
really doing something useful Wow cool
this is cool I'm gonna win ya in two
seventy and two double-oh-seven we try
hard to make sure the students know that
they have the freedom to try something
different
just get your instructor on board and
say you know what I don't know if I'm
gonna do this or not but I want to try
this crazy thing and that's okay because
it's not about winning the competition
it's about doing a meaningful good job
and I start the class off first lecture
I said okay everyone wants to win this
contest but first of all it's not a
contest it's a celebration it's a just a
great geeking time get together with
your robots in yo we're gonna have fun
because statistically everyone here is
going to lose because your chances of
winning are only one in a hundred and
twenty so like chill out relax have fun
and when you're having fun
hey you will do better and B when other
people ask you for help or you see
someone needs help and you help them you
learn and the more you learn the better
chance you will of doing better yourself
and that's true in your professional
life also you compete like crazy and you
get a lot of kudos for helping other
people one of the things that teaches by
the way is that ideas are cheap the
combination of ideas and execution and
excellence in the whole process and what
really matters so occasionally someone
would keep their secret you know they
would say this is my idea and I'm
telling you buddy and they would do that
for a while and they looked out into the
wait a minute everybody else has had the
same idea and they chose not doesn't
maybe this is not maybe I'll talk to
people about what I want
[Music]
[Applause]
when your student failing early and
often is a very healthy thing to go to
because every time that happened pick
yourself out say I now understand
something that was very important here
I'm gonna use that information go
forward if you don't fail you will never
have fun trick is to learn how to fail
and that's a very important part of what
we want to teach them in this class it's
also nice to have an environment in
which failing is okay the competition is
always designed so that lots of ways to
go and consequently there are a lot of
ways to hide your ego you can try
something that has a very low
probability of work but your instructor
- hey go for it later in life if you
have not established a faith in your own
ability to be creative it's really hard
to do that when the stakes are so high
if you make a mistake you might lose
your job so while you have a chance to
test your creative wings you better do
it
[Music]
everybody this is the final round on the
red and blue table for two
double-oh-seven
2003 the two table Scott ready one zero
one zero go
[Applause]
so you get back oh this is an exciting
mouth
Oh Lord Norris for noise for scores
higher higher higher higher
oh and it's tell the other table Oh
oh the block that means it's not gonna
move more oh but he get more way
[Music]
and it's better when
you pop stands for undergraduate
practice opportunities program it's a
program in the School of Engineering
that we have designed to help
engineering students gain a better
appreciation of the engineering practice
the workplace and to help them acquire
the skills they will need to be
effective and be leaders in engineering
practice out there we have four phases
to the program the first is a 40-hour
corporate training seminar it's called
the introduction to engineering practice
workshop that we teach during eiope the
second is a spring seminar series taught
by alumni that focus on career
development topics the third is the
summer practice experience where the
students do an internship for ten weeks
during the summer and then finally we
have a fall reflective experience where
the students come back and share with
other students faculty and alumni what
they learned from their engineering
practice experience and how it relates
to what we taught them I think in doing
a program that you pop the school of
engineering is making a very strong
statement about undergraduate
engineering education in the sense that
not only do we have to have our students
strong in their technical disciplines
but it is important that they have an
appreciation and have the skills and
ability to deal with engineering
practice as they are in the real world
the topics I was most interested about
in the you pop program were how
organizations work what engineers can do
and what their role is within an
organization and what sort of factors
you need to take into account when you
are planning a business such as
marketing knowing your customers and
working together with your whole team
rather than just your engineers to
deliver the product that people really
want there was a little bit of warming
up to do with the people I worked with
and I guess there were some challenges
they gave me my project for the summer
and on the first day I finished it and
they were a little confused as to what
what to do with me but I know I explored
around and I I ended up learning a huge
amount and I had a marvelous time there
it definitely provided
a different approach to things you know
you think engineering you think private
industry you don't necessarily think the
public sector people miss out on that
especially MIT students they miss out on
the opportunity to explore other realms
did you have these great companies who
come here recruit the students provide
them with you know great packages for
the summer so it's hard to turn that
down and and to have that opportunity to
have some other opportunities available
like nonprofits or government or
whatever I think is a good off it's a
good thing for MIT students because you
need you need MIT students and all
aspects of of life including government
I definitely see myself really curious
and not just being able to come up with
an idea about marketing it because I've
seen these companies fail and this
company was you know on the edge for a
long time there and so now I'm really
really wondering I really want to learn
about what makes a company and what can
really make it great I think that the
you pop experience has been very
important to my MIT education as a whole
because it's really helped me get a
perspective on the technologies and
skills that I've been learning in my
classes well I know from my classes how
to get the right answer to a problem
from you pop I know how to put together
questions how to think about an
organization or new technology or about
my career and really how to set things
up so it's really taking a broader view
and incorporating a lot of different
elements from psychology managerial
science marketing pretty much everything
and when I add my MIT education to that
I feel very prepared for my career in
the future
[Music]
MIT sponsors a uniquely expansive
athletic department which features 25
intercollegiate sports 40 clubs sport
offerings and 42 intercollegiate
athletic programs
athletics are part of this notion of
building a community and building a
complete individual's education I
certainly feel more well-rounded because
of it I feel that I've had the chance to
excel in different aspects of my life
mit has the largest number of academic
all-america x' in the country with 114
since the program began in 1980 I think
it showcases that our kids are doing
exceptionally well in the classroom as
well as on the field at the beginning of
each season the football coach says
gentlemen the first priority for you is
gonna be your academics the second
priority is gonna be football and if
your list doesn't look like this and you
shouldn't be in this room
nearly 60% of our undergraduates compete
in organized sports at some level on
campus it's a good thing because I met a
lot of people that I wouldn't have met
otherwise why what see afterwards now's
like are you on my I am team so how's it
going how's your research they don't
exist for themselves they don't exist
for the Alumni to make the alumni feel
good we have them because they're part
of the educational experience
[Music]
the crew boat itself the 70-foot boat is
a micromanage system in and of itself
you got the administrator your coughing
and then you've got your powerhouse
you've got your stroke who is your
leader of your powerhouse and then
you've got your four and five seats who
are the peak of your boat and then
you've got your bow who kind of guides
you along in the little direction left
and right and so together you work in
the team to the common goal they learn
incredible amounts of about leadership
teamwork sportsmanship and courage the
willingness to take risks and push their
abilities beyond what they think they
can achieve I have learned to push
myself during races and during practices
so hard and commit myself to a certain
goal unequivocably and in a way that I
never had before
the MIT I knew in the 60s and early 70s
had a proper emphasis on athletics and a
tremendous diversity of sports and
really emphasized participation that
part hasn't changed but what's happened
is there's an even greater variety of
sports today if MIT doesn't have
something be it a club or an
organization or a sport if two people
want to do it don't let you organize it
and you can have it it's up to the
individual but the MIT will embrace that
it always has been in the past and
always will be about opportunity for all
one of the things that I think is
particularly striking about the athletic
program at MIT is the emphasis on
participation in sports rather than
spectator sports you don't see the whole
campus coming out to watch the football
game on a Saturday afternoon like you
might find on some college campuses but
you do see an incredible number of
students that are engaged currently
about 20% of the students are involved
in a varsity sport about 80 percent of
the students are involved in intramural
sports and 100 percent of the
undergraduates are involved in the
physical education programs so it really
lets students pursue their interests
whether they pursue them as an
extracurricular activity through their
school previously or whether it's
something brand-new we've been able to
make major investments in facilities and
support services that have enhanced an
already vital program
the biggest single change has been the
opening of this is Igor set the Z Center
nothing is just beautiful man it just
seemed like the MIT campus became
healthier because people were more
willing to work out because there were
more facilities than they were nicer the
new facilities have been made possible
because there was a vision on the part
of MIT but then the facilities could not
have been created without the financial
support of the alums who have come forth
to say yes we recognize that that is an
important priority and we want to be
able to support it you'll be in there
lifting race and your professor will be
in there looking but it's also or
something and say hi to them and just
little things like that seeing people
outside of the classroom and interacting
not an academic way I think really helps
build the community it's not just about
the classroom or just about the
laboratory but it's about growing as a
person and part of that is working with
other students or participating in
sports or other sort of events the arts
all of which will carry forward into
their future lives
[Music]
when I came as a freshman coming in is
all these things thrown at you so many
activities to do so many organizations
and that's what's really so impressed
about this place is that everyone's
passionate about something you have to
talk to them for five minutes and you'll
start to hear about it I think what
surprised me most is really just how
much there is to do and how many people
are doing this stuff like there's a club
for almost anything you can imagine and
there's enough people to actually fill
the club - we're about to perform an
opera made up on the spot from Italy let
the Opera begin I can't hear my tea I
was interested in computer science
measuring Boston like the arts my
favorite type of artists and I love to
dance Samba dancing since I was two
[Music]
I've been studying mechanical
engineering at MIT and during this time
I've been here I've been really involved
in the hobby shop
I came to MIT to major in computer
science the walls here I discovered lion
dance
[Music]
what I also found here is a passion for
service on a scale which is different
from anything that I had really been
able to conceive of I was a coordinator
of the freshman leadership program I've
also done a lot of work within the
community at different schools in the
Cambridge system the thing that I'm most
involved in right now is MIT Africa
internet technology initiative I play
both field hockey and lacrosse I am
involved in a sorority Alpha fee I'm a
small group leader a small group Bible
study leader for Asian Christian
Fellowship and I was involved in the MIT
cross-products which is the only
Christian acapella group on campus the
range is just so large it would take a
huge amount of times to enumerate the
opportunities and in some sense this
challenge for the student is figuring
out which of those things they want to
do because they can't do everything they
can't even do a small fraction of
everything
[Music]
I like working on projects where I'm
dealing with the smaller things in life
the little things that perturb you every
day and this problem with waking up in
the morning is certainly something that
I used to think about a lot when I was
waking up you know I would hit the
snooze box news button accidentally for
up to two hours or even accidentally
turned the alarm clock off so this was
just sort of a way I could include some
sort of playfulness and inside
technology and solve a problem without
adding complexity alarm clocks are
traditionally very annoying devices and
I wanted to create something that was
playful and meaningful and that could
sort of even excite some laughter and
one of the most hateful times of the day
so I took an industrial design course at
the MIT Media Lab that inspired me to
create clockey and I came up with the
idea and they're sort of prototyped it
for a few days and from there I think
somebody picked up on it and realized it
was something that everybody could
relate to part of the goal of consumer
electronics research here at the MIT
Media Lab is to take advantage of the
intelligence that we can put inside
ordinary products to make them more
delightful to make them do the right
thing to make them behave in a
predictable and understandable way clock
II is a clock that has behavior and as
Gauri likes to say it has the behavior
of a somewhat troublesome pet that you
still love and in this case we also
think the behavior is useful and one of
the reasons I believe that we've seen
such a response from press and just from
ordinary people to Clocky is that they
understand exactly what it does and they
think that's going to help them wake up
in the morning the concept for a clock
II originally was not to use the most
advanced technology but to create a new
place for technology that was playful
and that had some personal meaning for
an individual's life clockey is made up
of a small computer inside that is
programmed with a random generating
sequence of numbers that control the
speed in the direction that clocking
will move in and it's connected to a
couple motors and a couple wheels and
that those enable it to move around the
room when you hit the snooze button
o'clock he will sort of roll off the
bedside table and wheel away on the
floor running in random directions and
speeds until if he finds a place to rest
and everyday o'clock he will find a new
place to rest so it's sort of like a
hide-and-seek game that you would play
every morning clock is of course a
research project at the Media Lab and
I'm currently developing a more
prototypes but clucky could be soon be
in production within a year the media
love is a great environment for a
project like this to emerge I've been
able to do everything from fabricating
to programming to coming up with ideas
and thinking about real world problems
all in all in the space of one lab well
I think Clocky answers a need that is
felt across cultures throughout the
world and that is being able to get up
in the morning when one really doesn't
want to and the snooze bar makes it very
easy not to get up in the morning well
in this case Clocky lets you use this
news bar once and then you have to go
find the alarm clock in order to turn it
off the second time and by that point
you're out of bed and it's a very simple
scenario to explain anybody who has an
alarm clock can understand exactly why
this is an interesting idea and the
kinds of responses we've seen from
people who have written to us or who
have written on blogs on the internet
around the world is that they understand
what this is about they may agree or
they may disagree but they can
immediately see what the point is
this is toddler this is doctor rustad
Drake together they're covering new
ground at MIT so we call the robot
toddler because it learns to walk and
because it toddles when it walks toddler
is a passive dynamic Walker that means
he is a simple mechanical device with
joints in the past the only way these
robots could walk was to trundle down a
slope they couldn't walk on flat
surfaces this is where toddler steps to
the front of the class he's simple like
the passive dynamic robots and he can
walk on flat surfaces - the difference
is he uses very little power to do so
we're letting the dynamics of the robot
do solve most of the control problem and
we just had a little bit of energy here
there to kind of push and pull the robot
and that's a much more energy efficient
strategy for designing a walking robot
turned out that the passive dynamic
walking was a great way to make a system
that could learn in real time on a real
machine the robot has a computer and
battery packs onboard and the steering
is controlled with a wireless connection
and a laptop but toddler does a lot of
the work itself because the robot
already knew how to walk down a slope it
required less work to find a solution
for walking on the flat dr. Ted Drake
gave toddler the ability to use sensors
that communicate with motors so with
each step the robot takes its able to
make adjustments and that's what we call
learning it's a it's a simple idea but
it's the best way we can embody what we
think the nervous system is doing to
when it when we're talking about
learning when we put it on the flat and
we start asking it to learn then it can
actually change the parameters quickly
enough that in we say 20 minutes it to
be safe in 20 minutes it learns to walk
on the flat and it continued to adapt to
the terrain as it goes toddler can also
be adjusted to learn very quickly but
with faster learning comes a price
there's this very interesting result in
learning theory which tells you you
can't have learning without
generalization the problem is when you
start generalizing then there's a
possibility that you'll overwrite things
that you've learned in the past so if it
learns faster the robot will walk from
linoleum to carpet with only a quick
adjustment however the return to
linoleum
may take a little longer but it's easy
to see that toddler has in fact learned
and that ability has enabled toddler to
tackle new terrain it's just such a
thrill whenever you see the the robot
walking and especially when you do it
and like in a public place and you can
see all the people go oh look it's the
cool little robot so how does studying a
robot that walks like a human actually
benefit humans so by just looking at how
a machine walks and understanding that
we can actually learn a lot about how
humans walk ultimately down the line far
down the line if we understand the motor
learning system better then there's a
potential that we could use that
information to design rehabilitation
programs even neural prosthetics to help
people recover from injuries or augment
their performance there's a lot of
different potential applications as for
toddler he's got a big brother already
in the works this new version includes
changes such as smaller feet new
components and a fine set of knees knees
that can both walk and swing through a
step will enable the robot to be more
versatile it's also one of the steps
being taken to make the robot appear
more human something dr. Ted Drake
thinks is very important for the future
of robot design when you see a robot
that looks like a human you kind of have
a tendency to reach out to it and it
really helps I think with the human
robot interaction dr. Ted Drake says
there is still much to learn from the
original toddler and from its new
brother it's an iterative process where
we basically start adding components
back in and see just how far the
learning can take us and once you've
built one and once you've watched it
walk the idea really sells itself I
think it's the first step in a long road
of building better robots more efficient
robots and learning systems for robots
so I hope
one morning I came up the steps of
Massachusetts Avenue and walk through
the door and the entire space had been
transformed into a wheat field
innovative visual arts projects like
that are happening all the time on
campus the Arts at MIT like science and
engineering at MIT are on the cutting
edge of their disciplines they are
serving the students and in the way
they're serving the students ultimately
they're going to be serving the entire
society at MIT you'll find some of the
best musicians virtuosa was completely a
person who lives next door to me has
perfect pitch and if you name any song
whatsoever he can strum it out on his
guitar if it has multiple lines of music
he can strum out all lines on his guitar
and you can see that it's indicative of
the level of quality of the MIT Symphony
Orchestra the MIT constable wire you
know etc last year I got to premiere a
song cycle written by an MIT composer
and that was a lot of fun
modern poetry modern music and
everything everyone at MIT cares about
something whether it's their classes or
their Europe or some student activity
they do there's always something that
they really care about the thing about
MIT students that I most appreciate is
the elegance of their thinking and the
fact that it's sort of live and let live
here
[Music]
there's a point of concentration that
any discipline requires whether it's
engineering or it's directed or acting
or paint on that point of concentration
is the focal point it is the thing
around which you organize your thinking
and your technique and so the fact that
there's ensemble work where people learn
to work collaboratively is something
that I see that people take into their
labs in a way that you would hope that
labs work collaboratively
[Music]
[Laughter]
well right now it's sort of the theaters
away I can investigate my own sort of
identity especially my own cultural
identity but I'm also enjoy theatre
because it's so such a collaborative art
and it's a lot like engineering which is
my one of my majors and I also intend to
pursue engineering and in that is so
collaborative and so you get a lot of
different people's perspective on things
I'm a bill earning I'm the curator at
the MIT list Visual Arts Center and I'm
here in our annual student loan
exhibition MIT quite usually has a
collection of artworks that students get
to live with for a year Art's are in
every new building now it's pervasive
from that point of view and it's
pervasive from the things that you see
people doing all over we find our
students a certain number of them go on
to graduate study in music and in the
arts some of them go on to become
leaders of arts organizations within
their communities some of them go on to
sing in organizations of performing
organizations like the Tanglewood
Festival chorus and in a couple of
notable situations I have myself a
number of times been engaged by
organizations whose presidents were
either in my class at MIT 20 years ago
or had been at MIT years before that
my first visit to MIT when I walked
through the halls I remember passing
through the math department on the way
to building 14 where we used to be and I
looked in a door and saw mathematicians
hunched in carols and I felt right at
home because that looked exactly like
walking down the halls of Julie right
into the practice rooms and seeing
people working personally on something
one of the amazing things about MIT
students is the the incredible wide
range of interests and abilities that
extend far beyond the intellectual and
the academic and our special guest with
us this section of the concert is no
exception to that his name is Jonathan
Lee
[Applause]
[Music]
I think that being involved in
activities like this only enhances your
education I think it's important that
while you're at school to to focus on
things besides your own research so
people come here as scientists as
engineers as mathematicians but when
they are making art they're artists I
[Music]
think that's so way of chilling out some
of the stresses you have that's a way of
looking at the things you're doing in a
with a broader picture
[Music]
so you shouldn't think that MIT has no
arts because they've got them like
sprawling all over the place well now
the advice I give to incoming freshmen
consistently is trumpet at home you can
use it here
[Music]
MIT is admired around the world as a
crucible of creative thought a force for
progress a place where dreams of
generations become reality MIT has done
much to make this the American Century
the Boston area boasts of several
excellent institutions of higher
learning but there is only one MIT mit
has shown a standard of excellence in
education and research that sets a
benchmark for universities everywhere
CHF out there just one year that's right
now China is very short of talented
managers but we would like to see more
than anything else is to see MIT helping
us to train these high-level managerial
person I promise I will pay what you are
paid here
[Applause]
thank you I personally and in Microsoft
have been incredible beneficiary of the
kind of work that goes on in here and in
other places like this here at MIT over
50 years ago there was a vision laid
down by Vannevar Bush that were probably
about Oh 20 percent of the the way to
achieve me I can't tell you how much I
have personally benefited from this
institution as part of this wonderful
campaign I would like to put hundred
million dollars on the table enough to
be disabled this is the age in which to
be so the disabled has a lot to hang
technology for I probably wouldn't have
survived and I certainly wouldn't have
been able to ride a best-selling book if
I had been born in the earlier
managing innovation and figuring out how
to actually turn good ideas into
products is is a really interesting
thing that you probably don't learn
about in universities it's not about
just technology it's about the way
people are treated it's about how you
motivate people
what was that inspiration which led
suddenly to the world wide web for me I
wanted the thing to be a project
management tool that allows us all to
work together not management in the
top-down but management in the working
together where so I then said it should
be inter creative
Universal space for people to
communicate through sharing knowledge we
are at the dawn of a true innovation age
it's estimated that the entire store of
human knowledge now doubles every five
years I would like to thank MIT for this
incredible honor which is I have to say
the first academic honor I've ever
received so it's nice to start at the
top this is such a great institution
dedicated to the search for the new and
and to the openness of thought that that
search requires this case is is the
great test of where we stand on the
issue of freedom and solidarity and the
future of our own culture
we're in the end I believe the real
challenge of history is to resist the
tendency so prevalent today to label to
stereotype to expose to denigrate and
instead to bring common sense and
empathy to our subjects so that the past
can truly come alive if only for a few
moments in all of its beauty glory
sadness and complexity young people like
you are always the vanguard of any
social movement setting an energetic
tone of courage and commitment and now
we need you to once again lead us to a
higher and more noble destiny 21st
century America belongs to you take good
care of it
thank you and god bless you
you